what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with another installment of
beyond omega level where we go over the
most powerful characters and comics and
for today's video we are discussing one
of the most powerful characters in dc
comics that you all forgot about
perpetua quite literally everybody
forgot about her i forgot about her i
completely forgot she existed until we
made this so perpetual was created by
scott snyder james tinion jim chung and
jorge jimenez and first appeared in
justice league volume 4 issue number 8
and 2018. as for her comic book origin
well it dates back to the beginning of
time in the dc universe when all that
existed was the source of all things
which is basically just what its name
implies the energy that gives birth to
everything in creation now the source
along with the presence which is
basically the supreme deity of the dc
universe created seven essential
energies known as the seven forces of
the universe which included anti-crisis
energy the speed force the emotional
spectrum life force the sphere of gods
the dimensional superstructure
collective unconscious and faithfulness
which together make captain planet
actually they just form the fabric of
reality but the source then created a
race of celestial beings known as the
hands and charged them with using
anti-crisis energy to bring life to the
infinite multiverse to fill the void of
creation but with the creation of each
multiverse the hand that created it
would effectively die and return to the
source now one of the hands rejected
this fate and tried to use crisis energy
the opposing force of anti-crisis energy
to create the dc multiverse that would
exist in a perpetual succession of
crises that would repeatedly alter its
reality now when perpetua created the
multiverse 20 billion years ago she also
created three sons to inhabit it mar no
vu the over monitor alpheus the world
forger and mobius the anti-monitor with
each of these three assigned to monitor
the realms of positive matter dark
matter and anti-matter respectively now
instead of passing on perpetua continued
living to watch over the work of her
children now over the next five billion
years perpetua created a race of apex
predators by combining martians with
humans which prompted her sons to alert
the hands of what she was doing the
hands then send the cosmic raptor which
is basically just a huge bird made of
cosmic energy to punish perpetua now
perpetua is defeated by the cosmic
raptor and is then imprisoned within the
source wall which separates the
multiverse from the source and then she
just remains there for a ridiculously
lengthy amount of time watching the
multiverse evolve without her influence
now knowing that the multiverse was
destined to die which would mean she
would also die perpetua influences her
son mobius to cause the first dc crisis
the crisis on defenders event which
would reboot the entire dc universe and
would also create a crack in the source
wall allowing perpetua an opportunity to
whisper into the multiverse and cause a
series of subsequent crises over the
next several decades finally the source
wall is broken by an invasion from the
dark multiverse which freed perpetua and
later perpetua would have her physical
form resurrected by lex luthor as he
endeavored to collect all the dark
energies in the universe so as you guys
can tell the origin of perpetua is
basically dc comics attempt to reconcile
and make sense of all the crisis events
which they didn't do a good job of doing
but as for her powers perpetua is pretty
much omnipotent meaning that there is
very little she cannot do she's one of
the most powerful entities in all of dc
comics which is evident by the fact that
she created the entire dc multiverse as
we know it really that should be the
only feat we need to consider because
that clearly makes her beyond omega
level but we'll cover a few more of the
impressive things she's done as if we
needed to so she created the world
forger the monitor and the anti-monitor
each of which are extremely powerful
beings in their own right and she was
able to battle the three of them merged
together to form the ultra monitor quite
easily and it's important to note here
that at this point she's not at full
power she's vast enough and powerful
enough to hold the entire multiverse in
her hands and she can emit enough energy
that it rivaled the big bang and which
could expand indefinitely now perpetua
is capable of destroying entire
universes as she done on multiple
occasions including earth 19 which is
the universe in which the elseworlds
story gotham by gaslight takes place now
in order to do this she had to expend a
massive amount of energy and she
remarked that it had been eons since
she'd wielded enough energy to destroy a
universe because she'd basically been
locked away in the source wall for a
billion years so she hadn't been doing
exercises the way she was supposed to
not only that she's so ridiculously
powerful that upon her release from the
source wall nearly all of the new gods a
super powerful race of beings began to
unravel and disappear from existence
furthermore the source while breaking
down which was caused by perpetua was
felt across all of creation including
not only new genesis the home of the new
gods but also in heaven where the
specter remarked that creation itself
was being attacked now in addition to
wielding ridiculous amounts of energy to
destroy things perpetua is also capable
of large-scale reality manipulation
meaning she can literally just erase
things from existence on a universal
level of course she did this with johnny
quick the version of the flash from
earth 3 the home of the crime syndicate
which is an evil version of the justice
league perpetua is capable of not only
destruction but also creation and she
can form entire planets at her
fingertips now she's also able to
completely control all forms of matter
positive matter dark matter and
antimatter which makes sense because
she's the creator of all of them she's
also able to alter matter as she did
when she merged humans and martians into
apex predators and she would actually
repeat this feat later when she turned
the citizens of earth 3 as well as lex
luthor into apex predators and actually
i should probably do a beyond omega
level video on apex predator in the
future so let me know in the comments if
that's something you guys want to see
but regardless another example of
perpetua's matter manipulation abilities
occurs when she turns the super villain
brainiac into her throne that she's able
to then use to capture the rest of the
legion of doom she was also able to
change the landscape of earth zero so
that its land masses were shaped like
bats so that it could serve as an
appropriate home for the world of the
batman who laughs now perpetua can also
produce a psychic whisper that she can
send through the multiverse which has
been the catalyst for many villains
including the anti-monitor darkseid
parallax alexander luther jr and
barbados the villain from the dark
knights medal event to undertake some of
the most destructive deeds so what this
means is that not only did perpetua
create the dc multiverse but she was
also responsible for almost all of the
events that threatened its existence
like the original crisis on infinite
earth's event zero hour infinite crisis
final crisis and dark knights medal now
perpetua is without a doubt beyond omega
level and honestly there should probably
be a tear for beyond beyond omega level
just for characters like her but even
still her powers are not without limits
she can expend her energy and need time
to gather more to get back to full
strength and in the end she's defeated
by an entity that we will definitely
cover here in the series which is
basically called the darkest night which
is essentially an insanely powerful
version of the batman who laughs made of
pure darkness but again we'll cover that
more if we ever get around to it depends
on whether or not you guys want to see
that or not but even though she was
ultimately killed perpetua is still one
of the most powerful beings that the dc
comics multiverse has ever seen but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace